volunteers serve breakfast at this
checkpoint for migrants on the border of
Peru
dozens of Venezuelans arrived here this
morning they're hoping to make a fresh
start in a new country ernesto came here
with his brother because he has a sick
son back home whose medication he
couldn't afford anymore without his
father's help the boys health is at
severe risk but authorities in Peru
won't let Ernesto in without a passport
what am I supposed to do now I have no
money what am I going to do
I left a child with special needs in my
Cabo I had to sell all my work equipment
to buy him his monthly supply and what
now how do I get back what will I work
with if I return illegally that will put
me in jail that's no option like Ernesto
many others with no documentation
arrived here too late they were
transported for free all the way through
Ecuador only to find the Peruvian
borders had already closed the buses
were delayed I should have arrived here
last night at 8 p.m. but the bus took 24
hours to get here my legs are swollen
because I'm pregnant and the bus had no
toilet and we only made one stop I spent
a lot of time without food as well
everyone here is desperate and tired
they've spent all their money on the
journey and can't afford to go back to
Venezuela their hopes of escaping misery
could crumble with this new regulation
these Venezuelans arrived here this
morning and are stranded now because
Peru started asking for a passport and
they don't have one now they are asking
that country to grant them asylum but
dozens others didn't arrive here because
they were afraid that they could be
arrested or deported a few kilometers
away from the immigration post is this
bridge a porous border were many managed
to get through with no documentation
here in aguas Verdi's commerce flows as
if there was no border at all and even
Venezuelans can get from one side to
another without having to identify
themselves we sell these Venezuelan
dumplings in Ecuador's Rallos in Peru
we go to the bars and shops and they get
sold that's how we survive tikal
national Manta name but there are also
dangerous areas to cross where smugglers
and thieves lie in wait all the time
still for many the risk is worth it